we need to be an elite team of people
that want to win want to challenge
themselves in life okay and want to go
to the next level and that's who we are
that's the platform that we offer and I
say to my team I said to my team my
kickoff today you can work for a
business that offer flexi hours
part-time 9 to5 all of that yeah
and do 100K a year or 200k a year or
come work for us be challenged be
motivated Be Inspired be part of a
vision be part of a team and culture be
part of a business that can improve you
and income work for us and that's the
difference you can put you can CH each
part we don't want people that want to
choose PA a there's recruiters out there
that probably might see and say oh you
know you can't drive a business like
this people told me that 3 years ago
yeah there's so many people out there
that are winners I want people that are
hungry I want to give people an
opportunity within this business to show
that they have a platform to be
absolutely great and that's what we
offer